- People want to know
if President Biden's vaccine
mandates are constitutional.
And the answer is probably yes.
The first vaccine mandate with
respect to federal employees.
Well, the President is the executive
and he can set some rules with
respect to federal employees.
He can also set a lot of rules
with respect to federal contractors.
Now, the second mandate
involves employers and employees
who are not part of
the Federal Government.
That one is on more shaky ground,
but that is also probably
still constitutional.
Why?
Because President Biden is using OSHA.
Now OSHA has existed for 50 years.
And the whole reason that OSHA exists
is to create safe working
environments for employees.
Now, normally making a rule under OSHA
would take six to 10 years,
but here President Biden is using
an Emergency Temporary Standard
that can only go into
effect for six months.
And while courts do look at these
ETS temporary standards very carefully,
it's likely that he's
going to prevail here.
And under the Jacobson case,
the constitution isn't
going to stop the President
from mandating a vaccine.
So while we may see people in court,
it's probably not gonna work
on these vaccine mandates.